una estrecha Victoria en Georgia
definida en segunda vuelta el demócrata
Rafael guarnoch ganó la reelección en la
carrera al senado con el 51,4% de los
votos y se impuso frente a republicano y
estrella del fútbol americano hershe
Walker quien obtuvo el 48,6% en Atlanta
World celebró la victoria junto a su
familia y seguidores
es para mí un honor utilizar las cuatro
palabras más poderosas dichas durante
una democracia
la gente ha hablado
mientras que la cámara de representantes
quedó en manos de los republicanos con
El Triunfo de warnock los demócratas
consolidan su mayoría en el senado con
51 escaños el partido demócrata rompe
con la paridad que durante dos años los
ha hecho depender del voto de desempate
de la vicepresidenta camala Harris en su
condición de presidenta del senado
tampoco dependerán del senador demócrata
Joe manching que a pesar de hacer parte
del partido de gobierno es defensor de
los combustibles fósiles y ha bloqueado
iniciativas en materia ambiental del
presidente estadounidense Joe biden los
resultados de Georgia favorecen a biden
en su agenda legislativa hasta que
termine su primer mandato en 2024 y
representan una derrota para el
expresidente Donald Trump quien era
cercano al candidato Derrotado
Georgia se consolida como un bastión
demócrata en el senado Pues los dos
escaños asignados para este estado se
pintaron de azul en las elecciones de
medio término junto con warnock en la
cámara alta del Congreso estará John
osov también demócrata las elecciones
celebradas el martes en el Estado Sureño
fueron la segunda vuelta de los comicios
de medio mandato celebrados el 8 de
noviembre en los cuales ninguno de los
dos aspirantes logró superar la Barrera
del 50% de los sufragios